[Music]
thank you
puppy again another one
what is going on today
what
look out
hey Val yeah is this really our first
appointment yes it is oh you're kidding
me no she's an exam too waiting for you
oh this is gonna be fantastic
hi Jeff Hi how are you oh my goodness
I'm a foster mom for all animals this is
baby V but her given name is Veronica hi
Veronica she's a fainting goat Veronica
is a mixed breed goat and she is
definitely pygmy because she's very very
tiny and she definitely has some
fainting go dinner because when she gets
nervous she tips over and faints which
actually really is a painting it's
actually a muscle issue and they get
really stiff if they're nervous or
excited she just I was over in her feet
stick up it's really cute she's about
four or five months old I got her from
some friends who knew I did Foster work
so I'm looking for a forever home I just
want to make sure she's in good shape
and good bill of health before we move
her on oh she is so so darn cute we're
gonna just check Veronica out for
General Health and Wellness hi baby
goats are incredibly smart animals
they're really as emotionally connected
and bonded to people as dogs
well she sounds great good we want to
make sure that she didn't come with any
goodies
he says what are you doing and doesn't
have any underlying disease that she
could share we're about 102 which is
normal
with any itching or scratching no does
that feel good do you like your hair
combed oh my gosh
[Laughter]
oh look at what I found uh oh see that
moving around right there she's got the
lysis right there we see that a lot
right now in animals that are living
outside they huddle when they're cold
and so that's how lice are spread there
is actually a topical that we can put on
her and that will take care of them I
think we're going to be just fine that's
an easy easy fix baby girl I'm not
really worried about Veronica slice
because lice are very species specific
so although they could bite another
animal of a different species they can't
play house on anybody else
so you definitely are not gonna keep her
you're just a temporary I prefer to
Foster you know I I've been looking for
something for the clinic so this is I'm
really like hmm she's kind of perfect
sized we've got plenty of yard out in
the back here we've got stalls that are
heated for winter so she could hang out
there and she's so sweet
is it all right I mean can we take her
today absolutely I will leave her today
and I will see her when I come and visit
I think she looks very happy here she
likes you I didn't know I'd be a goat
Mommy a nanny
I've always wanted to be a nanny
start my day thinking I was going to
have a clinic goat but with every door
that opens comes a new opportunity and
why not oh what do you have that look
what I got a puppy kinda
[Music]
this is Veronica Ben usually does not
bring home animals and surprise me he's
um
a little more disciplined than that I am
probably the hoarder slash animal
collector of our relationship for sure
yeah for sure oh I've brought home two
pigs scads of cats four or five dogs
pre-homed a few calves
I could probably keep going but I feel
like he may not realize that I did all
these things and now he's gonna know
[Music]
insane
Dad where are we going
we're going up to the hiney feed lot do
you know what a hiney is
yeah the hiney's a butt right
yeah
this is so weird since we're talking
about butts or high knees do you know
what we're gonna preg check today
uh donkey yeah so we're gonna check for
an ass baby
let's go chase
whoa doc Greg how are you good no school
huh no school you're lucky you know
Turkey
too many donkeys she's fully grown 38
inches Pearl and jewels
both are year old really friendly you
know they're easy to get along with and
pet them and look at them I guess but
all you do with them how can you not
like a miniature dogs they're cute you
know
I'm gonna put that probe
right on Minnie Pearl's belly and we'll
see if we can see a baby
okay this might be a little cold
these girls are tame
so you want to know this make sure your
jack is good too don't you yeah a Jack
is a male donkey and they're the daddies
a Jenny is the female donkeys so we are
checking out the Jenny's to see if the
Jack was good I'm not seeing anything
quite yet guys
[Music]
darn it see that right there it's kind
of a uterus that looks open to me
and open means not pregnant
okay well Craig I'm sorry
but let's check Jules
hi sweetheart
okay
there's her colon
where are you little guy
there it is
can you guys see that the legs kicking
right there oh yeah I see it's heartbeat
too it's moving all over the place
how far along you know my best guess is
about two to three months along
the gestation period for a donkey is a
little bit more than a horse so a horse
is roughly 11 months but a donkey can be
11 months 12 months
so it'll be a little while before you
get to have a baby Jewels the baby looks
healthy the fluid around the baby looks
great and I think everything is in order
here well it feels pretty cool pretty
awesome can't wait to see the little guy
come along or girl be pretty cool before
we go Craig also wants us to do a preg
check on his girlfriend's dog
we're just Craig checking everything on
the farm today aren't we I don't get you
up here very much so I might as well get
my use out of you
oh wow hi what's her name uh Billy we
call her bill for short huh Billy's our
honorary little Airedale pup my
girlfriend grew up around airedale's and
her dad raised him and probably better
dream to have another Airedale they're
great hunting dogs they're wonderful
companions
they have tons of energy we've got to
have her kind of on her side or back so
you guys want to see if you can get her
there
okay
Billy this is going to be a little cold
she's got some power yeah she's strong
oh there's babies all over the place
here
I mean she got in there oh my gosh I've
already counted three and I just laid
the Probe on her here's another one
heartbeat heartbeat heartbeat my screen
was just like puppy puppy puppy each one
of these black little vesicles is
basically holding a puppy okay right now
I don't want to speculate but you got a
big litter coming awesome yeah your
girlfriend's gonna be happy with you
tonight
she'll be happy before Billy the dog's
more important than me hey I know I know
what you're saying
dogs are pregnant for about 62 63 days
looks like these babies have been
cooking for about one month so in about
30 days we're gonna have puppies you got
to bring these puppies in to the clinic
when they were born we'd love to see
them and give them their first checkup I
love dogs but we've got our limit of
pets right now I got to keep Aaron out
of that exam room we do not need any
more dogs all right thanks a lot doc
give me heck like usual but he still
thinks he's a puppy he doesn't know he's
old his sacitude is still here
hello Cedar County Vet
it's okay we have a two-year-old lab
named Butterball that got dropped off
this morning for some unusual unknown
swelling around her head and neck
oh hi Butterball
and she doesn't want to get up
[Music]
look how pale she is oh no what's wrong
with you Butterball oh yeah look at
those gums oh why are you white as a
sheet
hmm
a respiratory rate definitely seems
increased she just looks so sad she's
she's out of gas guys that's her attempt
101.2 so that's normal normal temp
in my opinion she's losing a whole bunch
of blood out of her bloodstream and it's
going straight into fluid look at all
that swelling let's draw some blood and
let's get enough for a clot time is she
a farm dog they live on a farm don't
they I'm pretty sure you know it's fall
people always put rodenticides are out
at their bins and things and if she
happened to eat some rat bait that's
always on the agenda for here
okay Butterball
on the blood work we're checking her
clot times first one is off the charts
High meaning she's not clotting when the
dogs eat these yummy rodenticides that
are flavored so mice and rats will eat
them it binds up all the vitamin K in
their blood and then over time they
can't clot this is severe enough and
this is enough of an indication that
potentially like we thought she is
bleeding out
[Music]
okay Butterball Butterball is a lab
that's in the clinic today that's
essentially Bleeding Out internally we
really suspect it's because she got into
rat poison she's in pretty critical
shape where we are going to have to do a
blood transfusion
a transfusion from a healthy donor will
help Butterball replace all of the
clotting factors that she's lost because
of eating the rat poison we have a
couple clients that have allowed their
dogs to be blood donors in the past I'm
going to go make some phone calls while
I check on donors Ben's going to give
Butterball an injection of vitamin K
which is essential in the clotting
process
all right Mel I'm going to give all this
vitamin K this kind of burns now so
watch out
she is so sick she doesn't even care
does she
okay hopefully that starts working quick
might be our donor
hey this is Ben
[Music]
yeah
oh thank you so much yeah this this will
be wonderful all right bye-bye
awesome christensen's are heading down
they're going to bring their dog down
Kino oh good he's a big boy and he'll be
a good blood donor
[Music]
well we wait for the donor to arrive
we'll get Butterball
s of an update
her blood work shows that she's
basically Bleeding Out
we got to hold up our dog that's gonna
give us some blood for a blood
transfusion but the main thing is to get
her some new clotting factors and that
comes from the whole blood of a
different dog
we'll talk to you later bye
he said he just found out over in the
the hog house next to him where they're
raising pigs they just started putting
out crappy poison for the rats and mice
and he said do whatever it takes you
know save my dog
life it's just really amazing that we
sort of
made a phone call we were able to get a
donor right down here that we know
that's a great dog we always say in a
small town everybody wants to help your
neighbor good boy hi Kino it's your
moment to shine
we'll see you when I wake up all right
you're just gonna feel a little funny
good dog
hi sleepy
kiddo's gonna be a great donor because
he's a big dog he's got plenty of blood
so we can take what we need he has kept
on preventatives we've screened his
blood we are in good shape there you go
baby good hit okay
to pull off 450 mils of blood
well we're getting there we're almost
done
all right let's get this blood in the
Butterball
[Music]
we've got a filtered line going in
so we just really have to watch her
heart rate
I'm just gonna put it right here into
our port
is running
monitors going okay
hey buddy who doesn't love a Chenille
bedspread right he's gonna be all
snuggled in
[Music]
how's her color look at her ears
they've already have some color to them
anytime you do a blood transfusion on a
patient it's amazing you just literally
Watch The Life flow back into them it
really is like a rebirth thank goodness
you got her here I know you just never
know what things your pet is going to be
exposed to they're always looking for
things to get into that's their nature
that's what makes them special so you've
got to always be vigilant if you see
something strange always always please
bring your pet to the vet
looks like Kino's starting to wake up so
[Music]
isn't it cute
see how soft those toes are that all
wears off as soon as he starts walking
around
[Music]
hey girl oh I'm excited to pick up
Butterball all the kids are at home
waiting for her to show up and they're
all ready for her to be back home so
she can really see she's nice and pink
and her ears and her gum color she's
still got a lot of this swelling and
that'll just go down with a little bit
of time we have fresh clotting factors
from the blood lucky for Butterball
everybody goes the extra mile to help
their neighbor that's just how this this
place works in the next week or so we
want to be really careful that we don't
do anything that's going to maybe have a
cut a scrape so soft food and lots of
rest
have to watch football all weekend lay
on the couch with the dogs oh yeah I
think she's a little part cat she used
one of her lives here so you're down to
eight call me if you have any problems
questions or concerns bye girl
[Music]
we'll have you and Tammy go into room
one please okay very good brought Sammy
the cat he's 14 years old
Sammy's a rescue cat actually we got him
from Ben and Aaron right here in
Hartington
this was a cat that we adopted from a
client that couldn't keep it and the
Todds were looking for a kitty and so it
was a great match what's his story now
Joanne thinks that he's breathing kind
of hard and he is not eating worth
anything I mean very very little bit how
long have you noticed this three four
days okay
he's really working to Breathe Here
I know he's using his belly muscles to
breathe and not expanding his chest in
general when a kitty can't breathe very
well or is breathing hard it doesn't
take much to get him to really be in
respiratory distress so I would really
like to do kind of right off the bat is
get him on some oxygen here just kind of
make sure we stabilize and then run him
back to X-rays and we'll have to move at
the pace that he is comfortable yeah so
if that's okay with you if he needs to
stay he needs to stay okay we'll leave
no stone unturned there for him come on
come on Sammy it's okay I just hope it's
nothing really major that we can't fix
he's a big part of our family and I
don't know what we do without Sammy
so this is going to make something like
a hyperbaric oxygen chamber
we're going to leave Sammy in the oxygen
cage for about an hour or so just until
he's relaxed enough for us to get an
x-ray
stay in there peanut
all right Val let's go in and take a
look and see how he's doing
hi meow he looks better he's sitting up
he's meowing he's not gasping for air as
he's meowing we're better and we're a
little more in a stable spot for x-rays
[Music]
we got x-rays and there's something in
this chest that shouldn't be there
this chest that shouldn't be there Sammy
is a 14 year old cat that came in this
morning because he was having difficulty
breathing and the x-rays just showed me
why his chest is so full of fluids I
can't even see his internal organs he
has zero lung capacity like he cannot
breathe let's get ready to do a little
chest tap and see what sort of fluid we
get out
foreign
so the challenge is going to be to keep
him stable while we tap his chest
because obviously we're poking a needle
in between his ribs to access his
thoracic cavity and see what we can get
out of it okay are you ready
it's kind of Milky
obviously a little bit of blood tinge to
it
we've got to figure out what exactly
this is and what's causing it and so I
really want to get it to the lab ASAP
this is a lot of fluid
okay
you know I would say that this Kitty
really had maybe
like five percent of his lung capacity
you can really see the difference you
can see he's bringing with his chest now
instead of his belly
we'll give him just a little break put
him back in the oxygen tank maybe let
him have a little nap since he can
breathe a little better if we hadn't
gotten in here and tried to get him
stabilized and get this fluid off his
lungs we would have had a cat that would
have just drowned in his own fluid
I'm gonna see if we can grab some blood
quickly then we'll go ahead and get a
catheter in right away and just start
him on some maintenance fluid the goal
is to keep this guy stable while we wait
for the lab results to arrive
foreign
[Music]
hello there hey there I'm Dr Schrader
Kevin nice to meet you so what's going
on here I was driving down the highway
on my way to Sioux City and found this
little guy running towards me covered in
mud and I have no idea who he belongs to
and checked at a few houses and no one
answered so I looked you guys up
and thought I'd come in and see if you
guys could help me out we live in a
small community so we're not really the
shelter here we're not the pound but if
a lost animal comes to us we're sure not
going to turn them away you know we're
going to take them in and try to find
that owner does he have any
identification on him or no collar like
I said he was just soaked in mud and
shivering I opened the car door and he
jumped right in and very friendly and
yep very sweet you're a beautiful little
dog look at those eyes oh hi hi
yes he's he's a little boy it's okay A
lot of times we put a microchip
underneath their skin just to to know
where they're at if they get lost it's a
great way to be able to find a lost dog
okay so usually the chips are put right
there
endorsement on the back
unfortunately looks like this little guy
says No Tag found so he's not
microchipped what I would like to do is
just keep him here we'll do the best we
can to try to find out where he belongs
well Kevin thank you so much for
grabbing him I know a lot of people see
a dog on the side of their Highway and
we all want to stop and you were the one
that actually did stop you know so thank
you Kevin very well could have saved
this little dog's life it's cold out
it's getting dark it's the end of the
day that dog was a long ways from home
whenever we have a lost dog come into
the clinic it's really all hands on deck
okay everybody
we have a lost dog here all the staff
here at the vet clinic we put our heads
together and think have we seen that dog
before
silkies I got two boys but both of those
dogs are microchipped I got nothing
okay where was this dog found
let's make kind of a map and call those
people that live in that area maybe
somebody knows hello this
honey bad me somebody's been calling the
neighbor you know do you know where my
dog is falling to see
if anybody had called in a missing silky
terrier then we start apb-ing this thing
out you know the social media wanna take
a picture of him Val
oh there it is
this is somebody's pet and I'm sure he
means a whole bunch to their family I've
been in this situation with the lost dog
and it's no fun at all
you look and look and look until you
can't look anymore if you can't find
them you get up early in the morning and
you're looking again we haven't gotten a
hit yet but we're putting those feelers
out we just got to work at it and be a
little bit patient at this point you get
to stay with us tonight and figure out
where you go
[Music]
Veronica's Pathway to Clinic goat
basically started with an exam Veronica
you want a bath
immediately when I saw Veronica I I fell
in love I'm not sure how Ben's gonna
react to this she better be very cute
when she meets him so first up is going
to be your bath
did find some lice on her so after we
get her bathed and dry I think we should
treat her for lice and make her a nice
healthy Little Goat
you have to have a bath if you're going
to be a fun Clinic goat
I can honestly say I have never given a
go to Bath
stay in there stinker this is a new one
for me how about some conditioner
she kind of smells like a wet sweater
hi you oh my gosh look how fuzzy she
looks
[Music]
let's see Val I've got her little one
her little itty bitty dose of goat
medicine here for her lice this should
really do a nice kill here within the
next 24 hours I think Veronica really
liked your spa treatments
oh my gosh I love her
I think she feels better she's cleaner
and kind of watching her walk around all
fluffy and poofed up I mean she looks
like a beauty queen I want that when did
I go to the spa last
look at her she's so cute oh my gosh
someone wash my hair
[Music]
tonight I got a call from Chris burback
he got home from work then he noticed
that bloated calf there was like a
swelling on the calf side that alerted
me that this is probably a room and
bloat when I get that call I just jump
in the truck and go this is an emergency
Chris how's it going man good good how
are you doing problem with the rumen huh
yeah yeah I just kind of came out of
nowhere a cow digests her food in the
rumen a lot of gas can build up there so
she belches to let it out
come on cam but if too much gas builds
up the cow can't keep up
and we get a bloat okay
it's full yeah
the bloat on her side is is pushing out
like a watermelon I mean it's a big
bloat it puts pressure on the thorax in
the lungs and the cow can suffocate and
die
okay
there's a calf that has bloat in its
rumen gas buildup that puts pressure on
its internal organs
about how long will this take Ben it's
almost instantaneous to treat this calf
we're going to take a long hose put it
down in the rumen then we'll actually
push the gas out by hand from the
outside if you could just take your fist
and push that gas right out
you should smell some funky smelling gas
here pretty quick
anything yet
there we go there it is
starting to come
smell that yeah
oh wow look at all that froth that's
what's in her stomach right now we have
to put something that's going to
dissolve those small bubbles or gas
[Music]
we're gonna give her a drug that is
basically going to take all that froth
out of there and we're going to give her
a bunch of mineral oil to be a laxative
and get whatever's in her room and out
of there as soon as possible and water
to kind of help get these drugs
activated quick
Chris I'm gonna have you do the pumping
just keep pumping just keep pumping
until all that's in there okay go ahead
I think you caught it soon enough here
good
and in my opinion we're already gaining
on that room and it already looks a
little smaller to me yeah
okay
all right Chris I'm ready to let her go
yep Ready okay
come on sweetheart come on Dolly
before you go to bed come over and just
make sure she's running around doing
good yet sure and hopefully that blow is
less okay no I'm not sure it's going to
be all better until morning but please
let me know if anything changes or for
the worst okay yeah yeah I'll be in
touch with you
foreign
[Music]
today I want to go out make sure that
that calf has responded to its treatment
hello Chris hey Ben
how are you yeah long time no see yeah
yeah did you get up last night and check
on her before you went to bed yeah she's
gonna be doing pretty good blow one down
pretty fast from what I could tell but
let's get some eyes on him and and bring
him into the pen all righty so they look
comfortable chewing their cud laying in
the sunshine don't they yeah that's for
sure
come on kids turn around come on there
she is right yep good right up front
there we go
she seems way more relaxed than she was
last night yeah I agree you know it
looks like she has had a little bit of
diarrhea which is good that mineral oil
is working the yucky food that wasn't
agreeing with her is coming out sure
so her room is over here on her left
side and all the gas is gone she looks
great
she looks good in the eye she doesn't
have any signs of dehydration
bloat can be deadly and I'm glad you
called me at night it's okay you know to
to call yeah I felt bad a little bit
Ben's always treated us really good he
shows up when you call him I really do
trust him thank God it all worked out
all right let's let him back out to the
herd
[Music]
foreign
I saw Veronica I kind of just fell in
love I feel like you can never have a
bad day if you have a go running around
but Ben has no idea this is happening so
I'm going to test this Theory out
Ben doesn't like this goat then I will
find a new husband
hello might be a single later
[Music]
hey I will something for you it's an
exam room one
really okay well let's take a look
and just remember I love you more than
anything
it's a goat
she's a fainting pygmy and her name is
Veronica what do you think look at her
poop on the walk
that wasn't what you were supposed to do
on your first meeting
cuter than that I thought she'd be a
cute little clinic animal the second
year we were married Ben and I bought a
mama and a daddy goat and the mom was
really pregnant and I was really
pregnant and so this is kind of special
because every time I see Veronica I
think about when Charlie was a baby and
that just kind of brings me back I like
goats I know especially cute ones
operation Veronica successfully pulled
off
[Music]
hey
Sammy
why don't we run him back to x-ray Sammy
is a 14 year old cat who's having
difficulty breathing
there's fluid in there again
his lungs are being pushed up as is this
trachea we're still waiting for the test
results to show us what the fluid is
made of and that will give us a good
indication as to why this is happening
in the first place
hey Val yeah
Sammy's lab results are back on the
fluid we pulled out of his chest it's a
probable chronic chylothorax which is
really unfortunate I really need to talk
with Brian and see how far they are
willing to go for him
foreign
hi Brian it's Erin we took x-rays after
we got them stabilized in oxygen and
basically his chest was full of fluid
what we call a kylothorax which is
basically lymph fluid that gets trapped
in the chest there is a surgery to fix
the kylothorax in which we would have to
open up Sammy's chest and actually go in
and tie off the ducts that secrete this
fluid this is a really complicated high
risk surgery and in my opinion in
Sammy's shape and with his age this
really may not be the best outcome for
him their problems aren't usually you
know one and done you start looking and
it's just like an onion you know you're
peeling back a layer and you see another
layer and the problem sort of just
compound so that leads us to the next
question with how you would like to
proceed
course we can move forward however you'd
like and I'll let you know tomorrow all
right thank you so much Brian
you know it's hard but that's part of
this job that's
that's part of what we have to do
just sad
[Music]
Sammy is stable this morning but he's
beginning to labor again when he
breathes his owner just called to tell
us how he wants to proceed with the next
steps I'm so sorry
all right thanks Brian
okay bye-bye
I'm gonna say goodbye
they just don't want to see Sammy suffer
they understand that we've got lots of
problems and he's an old Kitty you want
to help me get everything ready if you
want to do a paw I can get get meds up
great
this is never easy but I feel like this
choice is for him
I don't want to see Sammy you know
struggling to breathe that's a horrible
way to have to pass away
you making a paw I'm sure they will love
to have that forever this is a a very
kind Choice it is
a huge part of
the gift of veterinary medicine is to
alleviate that pain and suffering
let's take him in he can just fall
asleep I'm yum yum
[Music]
for the last few days we've been looking
for the owners of a lost silky terrier
that was brought into the clinic
so after we left the clinic last night
we got some great news all right your
family's here
good morning hello hi we were calling
neighbors of the surrounding area where
this little dog was found on the highway
they called their neighbors and before
we knew it we had found this little dog
at home
[Music]
I have a question what is his name boys
Roscoe Roscoe okay he looks like a
Roscoe Roscoe loves to be around the
boys they like to go swimming at a farm
pond and he follows them everywhere on
their bikes and he loves to play and he
loves to cuddle me and the two older
boys decide to they wanted to go try to
shoot some rabbits I wasn't aware he was
outside and he doesn't like loud noises
when he hears that he kind of just
starts running and doesn't stop so how
old is Roscoe we're not quite sure
probably around 10. we found him in a
thunderstorm and then same thing running
down the highway are you kidding me so
he's got a history of running off a
little bit huh it does have you guys
ever heard of microchipping your pet
yeah it might be might be a good good
idea with him it's just a little
microchip that's kind of like a grain of
rice and it just stays underneath their
skin especially since he's kind of a
little bit of a Flight Risk here I think
it might be a good idea to just do that
yes
so this is the universal place where
everybody puts it
okay
I know I'm sorry
all done Roscoe got it you're okay so
let's scan on top of Roscoe and see push
the red button
and hold it right over the area where I
just put it
there it is there's the number so
that'll always go with Roscoe now Roscoe
has one of the best homes Five young
boys to love him and I want to make sure
he stays there
thanks Dr Ben glad it was a good ending
to this story happy ending
[Music]
Aaron and I are on our way to check out
a heifer who has a big problem with her
backside
and I was warned that it was really bad
come here Jamie
hi Amy hi Ben how are you good good to
see you hey hi Erin how are you good we
run a operation and this morning we
found the heifer that was prolapsed so
we called Ben and Aaron right away yikes
that is a ouchy butthole
holy smokes it is really common in
cattle to have erectile prolapse let's
call it what it is it's a butt sticking
out from where it shouldn't be right
yeah the inside of the butthole tube
goes outside like when you take off your
sock and you don't stretch it back out
like a tube sock they can die from this
yeah and so we have to get them fixed
fairly soon after this happens I'm glad
you called right away we'll get this
baby pushed back in
this looks like a good one for you I
don't think so
let's scooter up there
she's not thinking with the clear mind
right now
my girl
easy sweetie
all right
you guys looks look at all this mud on
her back I wonder if she came into heat
yeah and everybody kind of started
thinking she was pretty hot to trot and
that's what made her push this out
because something had to instigate it
all right so I'm gonna give her an
epidural there I went in okay two
sleeves
it looks like it's really taking effect
now and she's really getting nice and
numb back there we're just going to
squeeze this rectum and get all that
extra fluid out of it that's been
sitting in it you know here for the last
few hours it's kind of like an inside
out sock and we're just going to push it
right back into the body so see all this
this is just kind of
blood clots blood clots so I get rid of
all those and then
really I just start kind of pushing and
look at all that fluid that's kind of
coming off there
oh see and that's what happens they
still have some innervation to these
muscles and she's going to be one of
those kind that's just going to keep
pushing throughout this I think
you have to be so careful because that
tissue is fragile as it gets and if you
just even put your thumb or your fingers
you know at it look at it wrong it's
going to tear and you have a torn rectum
that's a nightmare
Aaron and I came out to a client's Farm
today to treat a heifer with a prolapsed
anus the only way to treat this is to
push this prolapse back in very
carefully oh oh heifer but she isn't
cooperating very much I want to get it
in but just because I get it in doesn't
mean I'm done
and so I need her to get her hind legs
underneath her and stand up
so my next plan here is to let her
loosen the shoe and back up against a
bar
okay go ahead and turn the Chute on if
we'll let her out
there we go
so that helps me tremendously
your arms all right yep
okay there it's about ready
there it went Amy good okay all right
good now let's recatch her head if you
would that was a workout
now that we've got our anus back in
place we're going to put some sutures
around both the anus and the vagina to
prevent further prolapses
all done all done she's got two bows in
her hair
very beautiful you did a beautiful job
thank you guys I think we just turned
her back out with the herd so she's not
very stressed
there she goes good looking animal all
right well high five Amy yeah
are you gonna fall back asleep
we just got a call from Craig that Billy
his Airedale had her litter of puppies
Ben is out on a farm call so I'm
handling this visit and he warned me not
to fall in love but
whatever
Hi how are you good good to see you
Grandpa yeah Billy how many puppies can
you did good well Billy's been really
good she uh licks him all the time can't
leave about 10 feet away she gotta run
back and check on them let's bring it on
Mama Oh Billy we're just going to kind
of do a well puppy check hi Mom Billy
puppy's really cute just a little butter
balls and you can't really tell them
apart they're all the same color they
all look like
oh this one is
okay all right squeak squeak squeak
but this one just peed they all look
great they sound great
and they are so stinking cute
my goodness they're strong healthy
puppies
that one's a girl
oh I want them all that'll work I want
to like rub myself and puppies yes
last one's another boy a big old boy
maybe we'll just send back nine
just kidding Ben warned me I was not
supposed to try and put a deposit on
anything he thought he might fall in
love with me I I do I love Airedales
they are such nice dogs I think he's a
little worried about me doing this
appointment it is hard to resist keeping
one of these puppies nope nope nope no
Aaron no
all of the puppies are within a couple
ounces
so you'll just really want to watch
because there's not as many spigots as
there is Miles so if you see somebody
losing weight you'll probably have to
get some milk replacer and supplement
really for their two day old check they
looked wonderful good congratulations
Grandpa thank you you have 10 beautiful
Grand puppies
thank you
today we're introducing Veronica to the
boys and also to happy and Skittles
a sister and she has horns
oh my goodness me Veronica your new
sister
what goats
we want her to be a clinic goat but we
have to see how she's going to act
around other animals so I thought happy
and Skittles would be the perfect guinea
pigs here to see how they got along this
is the test drive if they accept
Veronica I think everything's gonna be
good
what do you guys think
it's good there she goes oh she's up on
the chairs you know Veronica's being a
goat she's playing King on the mountain
jumping on the chairs
I'm boy dead
[Laughter]
she's head button him she's playing with
them like they're her
yard mates
I think the dogs are equally excited
that they now have like a moving snack
bar goat Pez dispenser come on Veronica
eat some wrapping treats all over the
place isn't she cute guys do you love
her she loves eating things and pooping
it's pretty cute that was basically like
the first six years of your life
the dogs don't they seem to be mining
your bird no and she doesn't seem like
she Minds the dogs
it's pretty cool we're giving Veronica a
forever home that's just what our
community is about if an animal needs a
home we're going to do whatever we can
do to help having an animal part of your
family it's just one of those things
that I wish everybody could experience
in their life whenever you come in your
door they're always there to greet you
and it's unconditional that is to me
what Veronica has done for this Clinic
is when people come in here the first
thing they do is see her and smile she
likes she makes me smile and pick up a
broom
she leaves her little bits of Veronica
everywhere
in the clinic on the floor and in our
hearts Veronica Veronica
[Music]